ei ei pessoal tudo bem
hoje vou ensinar como fazer uma pistola
semi automática ou seja uma arma em que
você só tem que puxar o que estão por
mali para trás encaixar ali e de seguida
é só tem que pressionar no gatilho para
disparar próxima bola
esta é a arma é muito parecida com uma
arma que já existiu e que continua a
existir só que já não é produzida mais
que é mauser e interessante nessa arma é
que ela vinha dentro da crônica ou seja
era uma crônica oca que tinha pistola lá
dentro e inclui as pessoas que usavam
tentavam como crone atrás e quando era
altura de usar era só tirar da cunha
encaixar na crônica pois encaixava na
ucrânia para dar estabilidade
aí pronto pois era só usar essa arma foi
produzida pelo sol mas inicialmente e
depois fui para a espanha e depois para
a china e foi produzido até 1938 ou seja
antes da segunda guerra mundial
mas claro ainda usar usarmos guerra
mundial é uma época em que as armas
foram os caças e pronto tive que mostrar
o funcionamento dela é bastante simples
por ser um caminho complicado mas na
verdade não é
e digo isto porque por compilar dele fãs
e de tubinhos e então vamos dar um
carrinho de cartão aquilo cartão diz
caixa de cereais de pequeno almoço das
caixas de bolachas que toda a gente tem
em casa só olhar ali na despensa e ver o
produto vem em caixa
caso vocês não tenham conseguido fazer
uma rifa bem apertada eu vou deixar o
link de inscrição onde vocês vão ver um
tutorial mais devagar passo a passo como
fazer tudo certinho
depois de fazerem rifa tem que usar uma
folha à volta dessa rifa para fazer um
tubinho no final tem prender confiança
por um celular tudo ok tem que segurar
vai é para aumentar o tamanho do turbine
tem ficar tudo a mesma medida
depois prender entre sítios é só usar um
pedaço maior e por um lado a outro
vejam que as medidas caso você não tem
visto muito muito muito bem next to you
dare rápido é essa por pausa ou então
podem ir à página do facebook lá vai ter
algumas imagens da arma cair as coisas à
medida que vou fazendo tutorial eu vou
ter muito difícil então vocês precisarem
de ver alguma coisa é só ir na página do
facebook vai estar o link de inscrição
já que é bastante simples eu estou fazer
como se fosse uma caixa de fósforos que
não têm as partes laterais lembrar eu
podia ter cimentado fazer com uma caixa
de fósforos e engraçado fazer vendas
caixa nem as pessoas não ter caixa de
frente
aí cria dá problema depois é só colar em
uma parte a outra bastante simples
agora vão ter que cortar um tubinho de
18 centímetros depois marcão sete
centímetros e partir daí vocês vão
colocar o carregador marcam o
comprimento o carregador e pois traça
uma linha não vai usar aqui um x ato
parece aquelas outras ótimas vocês podem
usar o outro qualquer e claro vocês
forem crianças têm tido ajuda o produto
cair
veja aqui a abertura de um carregador
tem por uma rifa lá dentro já podem
pular o carregador é porque vocês têm
por ouvir falar dentro para que não
fique nada obstruído o tubinho o sítio
onde vão sair as balas ok
ou claro lado pois do outro
estou usar cola quente é michael claro
vocês podem usar contra os colos é é
toda novo usar calça é button
aí porém também foi uma escola volta pra
ficar tudo bem era forçado não vai
extrair pois é uma frustração já me
aconteceu então convém sempre para
forçar bem página que o turbine ficar
todo o livro lá dentro não há nada
obstruir a passagem das balas futura
passagem do balde é isto biniki branco
que é do mesmo tamanho do vermelho é só
uma questão de design que o prosel
branco é pra dar um uso for sua arma e
na parte da frente que eu corto vai
ajudar depois encaixar o elástico que
vai lançar as bolas seguidas só por
muita cola em cima da parte por malha e
colar a parte branca mas tem mais quem
também vai estar né página do facebook
não vou poder logo quando quiser e cola
até deixe de ficar um bocadinho então
leva em conta o caminho de papel é não
faço como não só pela experiência dos
meus dedos é claro por exemplo já não
sentem nada e se pudéssemos equipe tem
cinco centímetros são 5 mil só coar
assim como inclinação os primeiro eu
tenho grande e depois do primeiro filme
senti esse ficam a mesma
na mesma linha cai para o estado outra
folha de papel e vamos fazer um cuidado
que irão estampar tratando lá e vão voar
como se fosse uma rifa casa maria só que
com tamanho poderá ter para fazer a
parte do gatilho
vejam aqui o tamanho de ficar na equipe
assim para fora
depois é só fazer uma equipe e um que
não estiver bem andar livremente é só
apertar mais um caminho até que anda
livremente
vejo também que até aquela parte final a
isso ajuda também é que sair mais
facilmente a opção por maio a gente o
puzzle quatro centímetros e depois é só
colar uma parte a outra uma coisa muito
importante que vocês vão colar de alguma
coisa vai ficar alinhada você põe cola e
profissional nem mesa eu estou por uma
rifa volta que os paulo ae
é muito importante que vocês porém isto
porque isso é que vai dar criando parte
da força da nossa estrutura
se você for ligar agora anda desta
maneira vamos perceber que é muito muito
frágil mas depois de vocês porém está
volta vão perceber que a força aumentou
bastante a cair é bastante simples de
fazer é só ir contornando e por cola
mas tudo é muito parecida mesmo com essa
pistola
então tenho de viajar twitter e apartou
crônica é porque como eu também fui
cidade na primeira guerra mundial vinha
lá as pessoas na trincheira
era só ter a crônica da arma e pulava
colocando na cabeça e conca e equi
pistola na outra arma até que foi bem
pensada
quando você puser em causa nestas partes
façam esse movimento para que o novato
foi escolar ainda internamente a cair em
punho mas se entrar dentro do lev dassin
de papel e tirem e claro forem crianças
não vão usar esta escola estranha a
supervisão de um adulto faça o mesmo a
cair porque esta escola se for na mão aí
fica a vossa mão toda estragada e agora
está na altura de fazer o pistão e vejam
a um conteúdo é que eu vá eu vejo que
fica a mãe do carregador marcar e para a
final e depois é só dobrar até chegar à
linha
esta parte é bastante simples isto é
para que protestou criar algo para
entrar as bolas para dentro da arma
vejam que tem três centímetros 1,82 o
comprimento vocês ajustam se vocês
quiserem fazer tipo um carregador maior
por mais balas
tudo bem mas não vamos pôr mais do que
oito ok vocês quiserem mais do que 18
que vai acontecer para você empurrarem
de baús para adentrar uma considerado
por um elástico com muito fora isso eu
acho que foi muito forte vai criar muito
trânsito nas primeiras balas que seguiam
a cair porque elas são todas
posicionadas lá em cima e as primeiras
bolas de feira não vão ser com muita
força é nem isso vai acontecer
acham que eu fiz aqui duas rifas com dez
problemas sentidos
vou cortar as partes mais frágeis depois
é só ver as medidas e colar lá dentro
para dar um pouco de volume já duas
partes
embora bastante simples é só ir fundo
cola a volta encaixar aqui e deixe de
pedacinhos de porco camisa não vai ficar
muito bom mesmo é pensar fazê lo assinar
por depois de pensar por si só tenho é
não aumentar em 5 bala japão vai ficar
perfeita
vamos ver como ele se comporta também
comida quando fiz aquela com elástico e
ficou muito boa mira estava mesmo então
vamos lá ver esta aqui são porque
iniciou para fazer isso projeto
depois é só pôr cobro a outra parte e
encaixar
agora vejam que a parte escrita ficou
por fora é isso foi propositado porquê
porque é parte está pintada não mentem
muito sozinha aí do outro lado
carregadora para pintado está lá dentro
ou seja vai ser para pintá la contra
para pintada e assim vai utilizar muito
mais facilmente a cair então isso vai
ser muito bom para que as bolas entrem
mais facilmente e veja aqui como fazer
esse balanço é bastante simples lata em
3,7 centímetros e no outro lado tem 2 em
maio
é muito importante que vocês façam as
bolas assim de outra maneira não vai
funcionar até porque isso aquela parte
uma icônica na ponta ajuda bastante é
que o funcionamento das balas saiu
sempre bairro exemplo foi fã depois
fazer um turismo não aquela coisa de
falhar saem sempre bem nada a ao formato
das balas
vejo que encaixar elástico e claro você
não estiver insatisfeito com força é só
dar um nome na ponta e pronto é só
encaixar os baldes com muito cuidado
foi lá que ela tudo assim não sei como é
que eu vou chamar aqui um momento
aluguer em portugal
e agora vejo um funcionamento
vejo que você só é só puxar me encaixar
em bloco não vai dar tempo xarém crime
mais preta daquela partida mas não cair
aí sim é que vai entrar puxam até que
quilo no retângulo micha para dentro
isso só chegamos ao fim eu espero que
tenham gostado se vocês quiserem ajudar
o canal é só deixar um like e se
inscreva para acompanhar as próximas
pois escrevo inventando e claro que
tiverem mais sugestões do projeto é só
deixarem na descrição que eu agradeço e
o próximo vídeo vai ser o concurso do
canal que eu espero que vocês participam
e mostrando que vocês inventaram lá em
casa então é isso aí só muito obrigado
até a próxima champions e é claro usar
óculos proteção e nunca te pará contra
ninguém
sejam responsáveis